on the outskirts of Paris the crew of a
catamaran collects floating waste algae
and even dead fish from the same
the river is undergoing an ambitious
cleanup ahead of next year's Paris
Olympic Games Remy de lorns worked on
the river for more than a decade he says
it's changing
the water has improved we are certainly
finding less rubbish than in the past
it's mainly plastic like bottles bean
bags and algae in a seven hour run we
often collect wonton
cleaning the river like this is just
part of a 1.5 billion dollar project
that includes new facilities to stop
more sewage and harmful bacteria from
flowing into the water particularly
after rain
City officials say that this once
heavily polluted river is now on track
to be fit for swimming and that's good
news for the organizers of the games
that have made the sin the centerpiece
of the Paris Olympics
it'll be the location for the first
Olympic opening ceremony to be held
outside a stadium and of other events
including the swimming leg of the
triathlon
we've achieved in five years what should
have taken much longer it's a real
success a legacy for the city and it
comes with the possibility that people
in the Paris region might also be able
to swim
swimming in the sand was banned in 1923
but paris's city council says it's time
to reintroduce it it's planning to open
three swim spots modeled on this one
that was open six years ago on a canal
in the city despite the Sen's appearance
at times some say they'd be ready to
take the plunge I have been looking at
the water thinking oh it should be
really nice to dive in but you know
there is uh chemicals and rats so I'm
not sure but maybe in the future yeah so
the Novi command would be tempting but I
need to know it was clean I think
they've started working on it and they
still a year until Olympic Games so I'm
confident it will be okay
with one year to go until the games
preparations in Paris are being stepped
up organizers are promising and alluring
mix of sporting spectacle and French
Flair with the river sen that inspired
artists and Romantics for centuries as
one of the main attractions Natasha
Butler Al Jazeera Paris